My husband doesn't cook, but he bakes.
When we got home late last night
and I asked him to make me some cookie dough,
he said he would
only if I made us some vanilla ice cream to go with it.
So after I agreed, he got started on mixing white and brown sugar,
adding some soft butter, an egg,
baking powder, baking soda,
some salt. Can't forget about the vanilla.
He gradually added flour and oats,
and obviously a bunch of chocolate chips.
This dough was so I couldn't help but snack on it.
While that was set aside,
I got started on making some vanilla ice cream by combining milk, sugar,
heavy cream, and some vanilla,
letting that heat up on the stove while I made my egg mixture.
Once that came together, I tempered my eggs,
poured that back into the pot,
and let that heat up before straining it through a fine mesh strainer.
Set that bowl on top of some ice to cool it down,
and then popped it in the freezer so it would cool down quicker.
This point, lucky started baking off the cookies
and batches for about seven minutes.
Once they came out, he transferred them over to a wire rack.
While the last batch of cookies were baking,
I churned my ice cream until it hit soft serve consistency,
added some warm cookies, and this was the perfect midnight snack.